die fraktion der afg hat den vorschlag
der anderen fraktionen widersprochen ich
habe daher den bundestag mit der
vorgeschlagenen tagesordnung einberufen
nach § 21 absatz 3 der geschäftsordnung
ist für die genehmigung der tagesordnung
ein plenar- beschluss erforderlich
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die noch zu beschließende tagesordnung
um die in der zusatzpunkte liste
aufgeführten punkte zu erweitern von der
frist für den beginn der beratung soll
soweit erforderlich
abgewichen werden
tagesordnungspunkt 24 und
tagesordnungspunkt 26 buchstabe d werden
abgesetzt
tagesordnungspunkt 18 wird bei den ohne
debatte punkten aufgerufen
ich mache außerdem auf die nachträglich
nachträglichen überweisungen im anhang
zur zusatzpunkt liste
aufmerksam
damit kommen wir zur feststellung der
tagesordnungen der 16 17 und 18 sitzung
mit den genannten änderungen und
ergänzungen wer stimmt für diese
tagesordnung das sind die fraktionen die
linke spd bündnis 90 die grünen fdp cdu
csu fraktion wer stimmt dagegen das ist
die fdp-fraktion enthaltungen sehe ich
nicht dann sind die tagesordnungen so
beschlossen ja das ist das übliche
prozedere allgemein herzlich willkommen
von mir hier vom kommentatorin platz zu
dieser sitzungswoche bärbel bas die
bundestagspräsidentin hat diese
sitzungswoche eröffnet zuerst mal eine
feststellung der tagesordnung
er reflektiert diesen sitzungstag am
mittwoch und jetzt sind wir sozusagen im
programm wir erwarten ja die befragung
der bundesregierung mit
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
eine stunde stellt er sich hier den
fragen der abgeordneten und bärbel bas
muss aber zuvor noch über einen
gesetzentwurf abstimmen lassen sie eher
in erster lesung hier behandelt wird
ohne beratung da geht es um den
leichteren zugang zum kurzarbeitergeld
der bis zum 30 juni verlängert werden
so das war die schnelle überweisung in
die ausschüsse also dieser gesetzentwurf
der wird heute nicht debattiert wird
aber in die parlamentarische beratung
eingebracht und deswegen das hier ganz
schnell und wird dann im folgenden den
bundestag weiter beschäftigen so jetzt
aufgerufen die befragen der
bundesregierung bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner hatte dass die
möglichkeit eines eingangsstatements
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen wir alle verfolgen die
situation der ukraine und die lage dort
die bundesregierung setzt auf
deeskalation
auf entspannung auf frieden das mittel
ist die diplomatie
dennoch darf sich niemand einer
fehlannahme hingeben auf die verletzung
politischer
rechtlicher oder
territorialer grenzen würde deutschland
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen und
transatlantischen partnern mit eiserner
konsequenz
reagieren wir haben
wir haben als bundesrepublik deutschland
in der vergangenheit die ukraine
unterstützt wir sind der größte
geber der ukraine wir sind dabei das
habe ich mit der ukrainischen
wirtschaftsministerin am vergangenen
freitag bei ihrem besuch in berlin
verabredet wir sind dabei 150 millionen
euro an ungebundene finanzkredite zu
mobilisieren und der bundeskanzler hat
bei seinem besuch in besuch in kiew
ergänzt dass weitere 150 millionen euro
zur verfügung stehen die g7 staaten
haben unter deutscher präsidentschaft
zudem an diesem montag ein kommunikator
haben klar gemacht dass wir auf eine
aggression russlands gemeinsam auch als
finanzminister reagieren würden und dass
wir im falle einer krise die zugänge der
ukraine zu den finanzmärkten garantieren
würden was immer vladimir putin
beabsichtigt eines ist ihm bereits
gelungen die europäische union und das
transatlantische bündnis stehen zusammen
und haben neue handlungsfähigkeit
geworden
eine zweite bemerkung
das bundeskabinett hat heute das 14
corona steuer hilfe gesetz beschlossen
uns mit dem deutschen bundestag jetzt
zugeleitet es umfasst die verlängerung
der home office pauschale die
steuerfreiheit des pflege bonus die
verlängerung und ausweitung des
steuerlichen verlustvortrages
und die verlängerung der degressiven
abschreibung für bewegliche
wirtschaftsgüter um ein jahr für das
jahr
das ist eine starke entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger und für die
betriebe es ist ein beitrag dazu die
wirtschaftlichen folgen der pandemie zu
lindern klar ist aber auch
jede form von stillstand des
gesellschaftlichen und wirtschaftlichen
lebens in unserem land richtet sozialen
und ökonomischen schaden an deshalb ist
es richtig dass auch auf veranlassung
der bundesregierung die konferenz des
bundeskanzlers mit den regierungschefin
und chefs der länder heute über eine
öffnung perspektive spricht mehr noch
das ist nicht nur sozial und ökonomisch
richtig es ist ein gebot unserer
verfassung das freiheits einschränkungen
nur solange und soweit bestehen wie sie
wirklich erforderlich sind
zum dritten liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sie wir alle beobachten die
preisentwicklung die inflation das ist
eine soziale frage die bei menschen mit
einem geringen einkommen entscheidet
über einen gefüllten oder einen leeren
kühlschrank am monatsende
geldwertstabilität ist auch ein
zentraler faktor einer guten
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung in der
marktwirtschaft insgesamt weil sie
investitionssicherheit verspricht in
einer mittelfristigen perspektive müssen
wir deshalb in deutschland und europa zu
fiskalregeln in unserem nationalen
kontext also der schuldenbremse
zurückkehren die reduzierung der
staatsschuldenquote in europa in den
nächsten jahren ist eine wichtige
voraussetzung dafür unsere notenbank die
handlungsfähigkeit zu erhalten
in kurzfristiger hinsicht wird die
bundesregierung aber ebenfalls maßnahmen
ergreifen und die bürgerinnen und bürger
und die betriebe zu entlasten wir
bereiten innerhalb der bundesregierung
zum beispiel die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage bereits in diesem jahr zur
jahresmitte vor die klare botschaft ist
wir setzen
makroökonomisch die richtigen
schwerpunkte um die langfristige
preisstabilität zu sichern und wir sind
kurzfristig in diesem jahr bereit
abhilfe zu schaffen wir werden die
bürgerinnen und bürger mit steigenden
preisen nicht allein lassen
vielen dank wir beginnen jetzt die
regierung befragen zu den einleitenden
ausführungen des bundesministers und zum
geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen kabinettssitzungen und
mit allgemeinen fragen das wort hat
zuerst aus der cdu/csu-fraktion der
abgeordnete florian oßner
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr minister sie sind als
fdp parteivorsitzende und jetzt als
bundesfinanzminister mit dem versprechen
angetreten die steuern und abgaben für
unsere bürger und bürger in unserem land
zu senken
sie haben es bereits angesprochen höhere
co2 preise eine extrem hohe inflation
höhere energiepreise und jetzt auch noch
die kalte progression wirken jedoch wie
knall hatte steuererhöhungen wie mich
wie möchten sie dem zum einen
entgegenwirken und sind sie davon
überzeugt dass ihre nun jetzt
angekündigten maßnahmen am ende in der
tat dazu führen dass zusätzlich geld in
der geldbörse der bundesbürger verbleibt
sehr geehrter herr kollege oster vielen
dank für ihre frage in der tat hat die
gegenwärtige inflationäre entwicklung
einfluss auch auf die steuerlast der
bürgerinnen und bürger die frühere
bundesregierung hat die
inflationsentwicklung für dieses jahr
2022 deutlich unterschätzt deshalb ist
unser steuertarif auf die aktuelle
preisentwicklung nicht angepasst worden
durch die frühere bundesregierung wir
werden in diesem jahr im zuge des
turnusgemäßen progression berichts
vorschläge unterbreiten sowohl für den
grundfreibetrag als auch für den
tarifverlauf
2023 und 2024
die kalte progression die
preissteigerung und ihrer auswirkung im
steuerrecht wird idealerweise
kämpft durch eine veränderung am
steuertarif das ist das mittel der wahl
und tier und die bundesregierung einen
fairen vorschlag machen
[Applaus]
herr oder haben sie eine nachfrage ja
ich würde gerne eine nachfrage stellen
und vielen dank für präsidentin dass sie
dies zulassen ein weiterer punkt zur
thematik inflation ist auch die grüne
inflation wie sie teilweise ausgeführt
haben für uns stellt sich die frage wenn
sich die ampelkoalition die
klimaschutzverpflichtungen und den
klimaschutz den sie immer wieder
propagiert wirklich ernst nimmt dann
muss sie am ende die preise für fossile
energien nochmals drastisch erhöhen um
zu den gewünschten verhaltensänderungen
zu kommen können wir deshalb davon
ausgehen dass wir in zukunft mit einer
noch höheren co2 abgabe zu rechnen haben
also noch wesentlich höher als die
vorschläge gegenüber der alten
bundesregierung um eben diese ziele zu
erreichen
sehr geehrter herr kollege aus nur die
frühere bundesregierung hat ein
klimagesetz eingeführt und dabei auch
einen hohen co2 preis festgelegt
wirtschaftswissenschaftler haben bereits
erkannt dass auch davon ein
inflationärer effekt ausgehen wird die
bundesregierung beabsichtigt in dieser
legislaturperiode die einführung eines
klima geldes wir wollen also die
einnahmen die dem staat zusätzlich zu
wachsen aus der bereisung von co2 an die
bürgerinnen und bürger individuell
zurückerstatten das ein beitrag dazu
dass marktkräfte bei der transformation
wirken können ohne dass es zu einer
individuellen überforderungssituation
bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern kommt
[Applaus]
es gibt gibt es weitere nachfragen zu
diesem thema eine nachfrage haben wir
oben aus der afg fraktion bitte sie
haben das wort
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister ich weiß nicht ob sie es wissen
die bundes umweltministerin lemke hat
eine anfrage der kollegin aus der
linksfraktion schriftlich beantragen
gehen beantwortet dass die
bundesregierung beabsichtigt die
entlastung auf höhe der preise zu machen
also den durch die steuern und abgaben
getriebenen preisanstieg zu bekämpfen
und nicht die mehreinnahmen nachher
wieder sozial an die bürger zurück
auszuschütten die frage ist diese
deswegen ist die schriftliche antwort
des bundesministeriums für umwelt auf
die frage der kollegin der linksfraktion
eric dass die bundesregierung den
preisanstieg betrieb von steuern abgaben
bekämpfen will oder wo ist es sollte es
so sein durch die bundesregierung wie
sie es können dargelegt haben dass sie
das geld nach wie vor komplett einnehmen
und der preis dem preissteigerung nicht
den gegen werken und dann etwas sozial
zurück geben welche lösung soll es denn
bitte sein sehr geehrter herr kollege
wenn ich ihre frage richtig
interpretiere dann ist die antwort dass
erstens auf die allgemeine
preisentwicklung über eine anpassung des
grundfreibetrags des steuertarifs und
des regelsatzes der grundsicherung
geantwortet wird darüber hinaus
beabsichtigt die bundesregierung die
einführung eines klima geldes um die
einnahmen aus der bepreisung von co2 an
die bürgerinnen und bürger zurückzugeben
und zum dritten wie eben ausgeführt soll
die eeg umlage bereits in diesem jahr
vollständig entfallen und das entlastet
von der rentnerin über den bafög
bezieher die familie bis hin zum
handwerk die breite mitte unseres landes
[Applaus]
es gibt eine weitere nachfrage aus der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
herr minister möchte sie fragen sind sie
nicht mit mir der meinung dass der
begriff grüne inflation eigentlich
irreführend ist weil wir es mit einer
fossilen inflation derzeit zu tun haben
die hälfte so ja auch die an die zahlen
der ezb der derzeitige inflation sind
getrieben durch importierte erhöhung der
energiepreise der fossilen energien also
speziell öl und gas auch getrieben durch
die aktuelle globale krisen situation
aber auch ansonsten nachholen beim öl
und deswegen adressieren wir doch auch
als bundesregierung soweit ich
informiert bin speziell dieses diese
thematik der fossilien inflation
sehr geehrte liebe frau kollegin ich
will mich jetzt an
interpretatorischen debatten und an der
politischen nutzung bestimmter begriffe
nicht beteiligen richtig ist jedenfalls
dass wir aufgrund der aktuellen
situation an den energiemärkten aufgrund
von lieferketten problem innerhalb
europas eine preissteigerung sehen wir
wissen auch dass die transformation von
wirtschaft und gesellschaft hin auf die
klimaneutralität sehr hohe finanzmittel
sehr hohe investitionen erfordert und
diese investitionen werden zu tragen
seien von bürgerinnen und bürgern von
betrieben und auch vom staat und darauf
werden wir lösungen gemeinsam lösungen
finden die dafür sorge tragen dass wir
auf der einen seite die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der wirtschaft
nicht gefährden sondern stärken durch
die transformation und auf der anderen
seite den menschen ein leben in freiheit
ermöglichen wo sie ihre eigenen
entscheidungen treffen können ohne zu
stark eingeschränkt zu werden durch
finanzielle belastungen
vielen dank da ich keine weiteren fragen
zu diesem thema
ok dann
sie haben das wort aus der fdp-fraktion
präsident dass es sehr freundlich dass
sie die frage noch zu lassen ich möchte
mich auch nicht an interpretatorischen
definitionen der installation
befleißigen allerdings doch darauf
verweisen dass die geldmenge m3 in der
eurozone gerade erheblich steigt was
eine politik der ezb ist wie sie wissen
die dazu dient letztendlich die schulden
der länder zu finanzieren die ihre
schuldenregel seit langer zeit nicht
eingehalten haben italien frankreich usw
wir hatten 2009 10 geldmenge von 12,9
millionen euro 2020 schon von 14,46
millionen euro und ende 2021 von 15
eineinhalb billionen euro tendenz
steigend was sagen sie denn auf
europäischer ebene sie gerieren sich ja
als eu freunde genau hin zu dieser
thematik sie wissen dass die gleichung
betrifft geldmenge ist gleich
preisniveau und wenn die geldmenge
steigt dann steigt das preisniveau das
ist eine volkswirtschaftliche
binsenweisheit die dir jeder eigentlich
kennt der in diesem segment unterwegs
ist und was sagen sie zu diesen
fundamentalen kernproblem der geldmengen
explosion die unsere leute letztendlich
aber macht internet
sehr geehrter herr abgeordneter
der
bundesfinanzminister kommentiert
entscheidungen der europäischen
notenbank nicht im einzelnen und gibt
ihr auch keine ratschläge
denn es gehört zu unserem
institutionengefüge dass die notenbank
unabhängig ist und keine politischen
weisungen entgegennimmt das ist ja auch
insbesondere der bundesrepublik
deutschland in ihrer
stabilitätspolitischen tradition immer
wichtig gewesen
ich nehme allerdings war dass die ezb
angekündigt hat dass pandemic im murger
purchase program in diesem jahr
einzustellen und das auf dabei auch das
asset purchase program angepasst wird
der chef der niederländischen notenbank
hat zudem einen zinsschritt in höhe von
25 basispunkten in aussicht gestellt der
beitrag der regierungen ist die
schuldenstandsquote zu reduzieren
konkret ist das ziel dieser
bundesregierung bereits zu anfang der
zweiten hälfte dieses jahrzehnts die
maastricht-kriterien von 60 prozent
gesamt schuldenstand wieder einzuhalten
und in europa beizutragen dazu dass der
stabilitäts und wachstumspakt einen
klaren verbindlichen schuldenabbau fahrt
vorsieht
nächste fragestellerin noch zum gleichen
thema aus den fraktionen die linke frau
lucia vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister sie sprachen über die
entlastung der bürgerinnen und bürger
allerdings war mir das ehrlich gesagt
ich konkret genug ich kann das auch
einmal begründen warum ich das genauer
wissen will nach den angaben zum
beispiel von eur statt hatten 15 5
prozent der alleinerziehenden in
deutschland im jahr 2020 nicht
ausreichend geld um ihre wohnung so zu
heizen dass sie nicht frieren müssen
aber nicht nur alleinerziehende haben
nicht ausreichend geld um die
energiekosten zu tragen und darum würde
ich gerne wissen wie sich konkret
vorstellen diese menschen zu entlasten
ob sie aus den zusätzlichen
steuermehreinnahmen etwas zurückgeben
wollen und wenn ja wie und an welche
personengruppen sehr geehrte frau
kollegin löscht die
bundesregierung hat ja sehr frühzeitig
initiativen ergriffen einen
heizkostenzuschuss
den wohngeld empfängerinnen und
empfängern bafög beziehern und anderen
gruppen zur verfügung zu stellen es ist
jetzt mit dem vierten corona steuer
hilfe gesetz noch weiteres mit auf den
weg gebracht worden zudem haben wir
einen gesetzlichen auftrag den regelsatz
der grundsicherung anzupassen und auch
ein progression bericht wird es im laufe
dieses jahres ergeben koalitionsvertrag
von spd grünen und fdp es zudem
vorgesehen zu einer neuen
kindergrundsicherung zu finden die
ebenfalls
bedürftige familien gezielt unterstützt
es ist beabsichtigt bereits im
haushaltsjahr
2022 im vorgriff auf diese
kindergrundsicherung
eine maßnahme zu etablieren
vielen dank jetzt lasse ich noch eine
nachfrage zur aus der fdp-fraktion herr
kollege gott schalten dann würde ich
vielleicht zur nächsten frage stellung
übergehen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter bundesminister lindner immerhin
in ihrem bericht eben sind rudimente ja
noch von dem lindner den ich durchaus
mal geschätzt habe als da in der
opposition war vorhanden sie sprachen
davon dass problem der kalten
progression erkannt zu haben nur will
ich ihnen auf die sprünge helfen in der
drucksache 19 7 6 9 7 gab es einen
antrag mit dem titel chance und tarif
stadt belastungs tarif abschmelzen des
mittelstandsbauches vorgelegt ich helfe
ihnen dann noch mal auf die sprünge es
geht um die kalte progression auch dort
es ist der tarif auf rädern denen sie
sogar in diesem antrag von der
fdp-fraktion kopiert haben weil sie dem
nicht beispringen wollte nun ist meine
frage wie sieht ihre konkrete antwort
aus denn morgen wird die fdp-fraktion
exakt den anlagen denen sie auch
eingebracht haben entsprechend ins
plenum einbringen und wird die lösung
sein die kalte progression mittels des
tarif auf rädern die kalte progression
stoppen sein wie sehen da ihre ideen aus
sehr geehrter herr kollege es ist eine
beklagenswerte
realität aber auch ich muss sie
anerkennen die fdp hat bei der
bundestagswahl die absolute mehrheit
verfehlt
aus diesem grund muss in der mitte des
hauses ein kompromiss gefunden werden um
eine gesetzesänderung mehrheit zu
erreichen und deshalb ist vermutlich
keine fraktion hier in der lage ihre
ideen exklusiv und eins zu eins
übersetzen in
gesetzesbeschlüsse und das betrifft auch
den von ihnen genannten antrag der
fraktion der freien demokraten aus der
letzten legislaturperiode
konkret wird es wie seit 2012 vorgesehen
in diesem jahr ein progression bericht
geben auf diesen progression bericht
wird die bundesregierung reagieren und
einen vorschlag unterbreiten dem
deutschen bundestag und dem bundesrat
wie darauf zu reagieren sein wird was
speziell die indexierung im sinne eines
tarifs auf rädern angeht so ist mir das
anliegen prinzipiell sympathisch in der
konkreten inflationären situation in der
wir sind könnte eine indexierung von
sozialleistungen tarifen und anderes
allerdings zusätzliche effekte auf die
inflations steigerung haben bei diesem
instrument mahne ich also zur vorsicht
ganz abgesehen davon dass wir als frei
gewählter abgeordneter immer kritisch
sein sollten wenn dinge die
haushaltswirksam sind automatisch sich
vollziehen ohne dass sie mit entscheiden
ich gehe jetzt zur nächsten
fragestellerin über aus der spd-fraktion
bettina hagedorn
herr minister ein kleiner themenwechsel
sie sind ja zuständig für ein großes
portfolio und ich denke nicht nur ich
und die spd fraktion sondern der
haushaltsausschuss und der bundestag
insgesamt sind schon ganz gespannt auf
die neunten märz machen den
regierungsentwurf für den haushalt 22
und den finanzplan bis 26 vorstellen
werden die öffentlichkeit und um unsere
neugierde ein bisschen zu zügeln wäre es
schön wenn sie vielleicht darstellen
könnten wie ihre schwerpunkte in
umsetzung auch des koalitionsvertrages
mit blick auf haushalt und finanzplan
sein werden weil es ja einerseits darum
geht die schon sehr hohen investitionen
der letzten jahre
noch mal möglicherweise zu steigern mit
schwerpunkt klimaschutz und
transformation aber auch die soziale
sicherung zu stärken stichwort rente
grundsicherung kindergrundsicherung
haben sie schon selbst genannt und dabei
auch das was wir uns gemeinsam
vorgenommen haben zu beachten nämlich
dass wir wieder zu einer soliden
haushaltsführung ab 23 zurückfinden
dankeschön sehr verehrte liebe frau
kollegin hagedorn das bundeskabinetts
vibriert vor gestaltungs ehrgeiz es gibt
eine große es gibt eine große ungeduld
jetzt alles umsetzen zu wollen
leider sind die
haushalterischen spielräume in diesem
jahr 2022 so begrenzt dass nicht alles
was wünschst und was sofort umgesetzt
werden soll auch direkt realisierbar ist
deshalb wird ist bis zum 9 märz noch
sehr kollegiale gespräche geben auch auf
der chefebene wo wir gemeinsam eine
priorisierung auf der zeitachse
vornehmen werden prinzipiell kann man
sagen dass erst
die bundesregierung bei ihrer haushalts
initiative einen schwerpunkt legen wird
auf all das was aktiviert also bildung
das geplante bürgergeld zweitens wir
setzen einen schwerpunkt auf
investitionen die auch die
wachstumsperspektive der wirtschaft
verbessern ich denke etwa an den
digitalbereich gerade ganz aktuell die
gestaltung der energiewende und den
ausbau erneuerbarer energien die ja über
die aktuelle situation und den
klimaschutz hinaus auch unsere energie
unabhängigkeit sichern können und zum
dritten wir wollen die schuldenbremse
einhalten ab 2023 das bedeutet dass jede
zusätzliche strukturelle ausgabe die wir
in diesem jahr verabreden sie sich
bereits an der schuldenbremse des
nächsten jahres messen muss das verlangt
von uns viel disziplin ab aber das
kabinett hat bereits gezeigt dass es bei
seinen vorschlägen diese disziplin
aufbringen kann apropos disziplinen der
rote balken hat eine bedeutung
vielleicht da das alle noch mal drauf
schauen frau hagedorn sie haben möchten
früher fanden sie es gut wenn der rote
balken wächst auf jeden fall
er hat auch eine bedeutung habe ich ja
gesagt
frage frau bundestagspräsident ich hätte
noch viele fragen aber zugunsten anderer
fragesteller werde ich darauf verzichten
vielen dank
zu diesem themenkomplex habe ich bereits
zwei nachfragen einmal der abgeordnete
janitschek aus den fraktionen bündnis 90
die grünen
ja sehr geehrter herr minister die
bundesregierung hat ja auch großen
gestaltungs liebenden gestaltungs
ehrgeiz bei der ausgestaltung der korona
helfen die jetzt noch ein weiteres mal
verlängert wurden bis zum 30 juni haben
wir brauchen unter uns die noch sehr
betroffen sind wie beispielsweise die
veranstaltungswirtschaft die
messewirtschaft
gleichzeitig ist heute abend die mpk sie
haben das beschrieben dass es dort auch
jetzt zu nachvollziehbaren und
planungssicherheit schritten kommen soll
auch das bundeswirtschaftsministerium
hat am wochenende vorschläge gemacht
aber wie kann man in diesem kontext
jetzt auch die äußerungen ihres neuen
chefs volkswirts raesfeld einordnen den
ich sehr schätze persönlich aus vielen
dialogen der gesagt hat müsste diese
hilfen jetzt eigentlich umgehend ändern
es ist tatsächlich erforderlich dass wir
schrittweise auf die korona hilfen
verzichten in vielen bereichen unserer
wirtschaft sind sie gottlob auch nicht
mehr erforderlich es gibt aber bereiche
ich denke an den eventbereich
kulturveranstaltungen da ist auch bei
öffnungs schritten nicht sofort wieder
zu erwarten dass es umsatzerlöse gibt
und hier ist ein schrittweises
herauffahren mit einer befristeten
verlängerung des kurzarbeitergeldes mit
überbrückungshilfen 4 bis zur mitte des
jahres vertretbar das langfristige ziel
indessen muss sein dass wir die
wirtschaftliche intervention des staates
in die wirtschaft beenden weil wir auch
an die physikalischen grenzen dessen
stoßend was möglich ist
nächste fragestellerin zum thema aus der
fraktion die linke frau lötzsch
frau präsidentin herr minister wir sind
uns ja alle einig dass es eine große
notwendigkeit an investitionen gibt und
wir haben ja gesehen dass in der korona
krise die ja leider noch lange nicht
vorbei sein wird sich für einen kleinen
teil der bevölkerung das quasi sehr
gelohnt hat weil ihre einkommen und
vermögen gestiegen sind aber ein großer
teil der bevölkerung eher weniger geld
in der tasche hat wie wollen sie dann
diese investitionen realisieren unter
der überschrift schuldenbremse und unter
der überschrift keine steuererhöhungen
für vermögende für große einkommen ich
glaube sie müssten wir doch eigentlich
aus dem herzen zustimmen dass es
sinnvoll wäre jetzt endlich auch die
vermögenden die superreichen und die die
in der krise profitiert haben
heranzuziehen um die investitionen die
ja alle nutzen zu finanzieren sehr
geehrte frau kollegin lötzsch in der
finanzpolitik empfiehlt es sich
entscheidungen nicht zu treffen mit dem
herz oder gar dem bauch sondern mit dem
kopf und deshalb sollten wir
sollten wir eine erholung unserer
wirtschaft nicht dadurch gefährden das
wir mittelständische strukturen das
handwerk oder die industrie belasten
ihnen ist bekannt dass deutschland im
internationalen vergleich
bedauerlicherweise eine höchst steuer
land ist es wäre töricht diese
international höchste
belastung die sich auch ergeben hat
durch 16 jahre nahe zur untätigkeit im
steuerpolitischen bereich dass wir diese
belastung weiter erhöhen deshalb wollen
wir uns darauf konzentrieren durch kluge
abschreibungen durch gute
wirtschaftliche rahmenbedingungen durch
die beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren
privates kapital zu mobilisieren damit
es investiert werden kann in
transformation und fortschritt frau
präsidentin da vorne leuchtet noch geld
[Applaus]
in der hoffnung das geld auch aufwächst
verstehe
ich sehe keine weiteren nachfragen dann
kommen wir zum nächsten frage stelle aus
der fdp fraktion peter böhringer
danke frau präsidentin herr minister
berichten von mode und der welt zufolge
aktuellen berichten ist zu entnehmen
dass die bundesregierung die
veröffentlichung von unterlagen zum
wiederaufbau vor der eu zu verhindern
versucht in fast 250 fällen hat das bmf
die herausgabe von dokumenten zu diesem
750 milliarden euro
verweigert sie hat sogar bei der
eu-kommission ein veto eingelegt gegen
die herausgabe weil transparenz an
dieser stelle zitat die internationalen
beziehungen deutschlands gefährden
können meine frage wieso hält die
bundesregierung diese dokumente zurück
wie soll die iso oder was soll die
öffentlichkeit zur entstehungsgeschichte
dieses riesigen fonds nicht erfahren
inwiefern hat der deutsche
umsetzungsplanung den geht's ja hier
dieses fonds auswirkungen auf die
beziehungen deutschlands zu anderen
staaten könnte dabei vielleicht
herauskommen um ihr gedächtnis möchte
aufzufrischen denn das sind ja noch
betrifft der teilweise auch noch die
vorgängerregierung teilweise dass die
regierung auf hohe geldsummen verzichtet
hat also deutschland statt den ihm
zustehenden 100 milliarden euro nur 25
milliarden euro beantragt hat also
eigentlich 55 auf 75 milliarden
deutscher steuer-euro verzichtet hat
danke
sehr geehrter herr kollege wie sie
ansatzweise angedeutet haben war ich mit
dem programm next generation eu und dem
wiederaufbau von in europa fachlich
nicht befasst weil das auf die zeit der
vorgängerregierung zurückweist etwaige
fragen müssten sie also schriftlich
stellen dann würde die bundesregierung
schauen was dargelegt werden kann
der berühmte menschen seine nachfrage
stellen gut angesichts dieser nicht
antwort muss sich eine nachfrage stellen
in den genannten presseberichten wird
explizit erwähnt dass nicht nur der
bundesfinanzminister scholz jetzigen
kanzler scholz sondern auch unter den
jetzigen finanzminister lindner die
herausgabe noch einmal explizit
verweigert wurde das war ihr eigenes
haus minister und deshalb vielleicht
doch noch die erinnerung auch an einen
antrag der fdp bundestagsfraktion von
mit 21 mit dem titel transparenz
umfassend gewährleisten mit der schönen
feststellung politische transparenz ist
ein grundpfeiler der offenen
gesellschaft ihre worte sie haben selbst
unterzeichnet wie erklären sie ihren
wählern dass bei solch einer riesigen
summe offensichtlich gemauert wird auch
von ihnen beziehungsweise ihrem haus ich
bin mit diesem vorgang persönlich nicht
befasst worden deshalb kann ich in einer
fragestunde dazu auch nicht spontan ohne
akten unterlage antworten ihnen stehen
andere möglichkeiten der
parlamentarischen frage rechte zur
verfügung und ich lade sie herzlich ein
davon gebrauch zu machen
vielen dank zu diesem themenkomplex sehe
ich keine weiteren nachfrage dann kommen
wir zur nächsten fragestellerin aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen frau
katharina beck
lindner ich freue mich sehr dass wir das
finanzministerium und auch finanzen und
die kapitalmärkte so als ermöglicher
sehen in unserer regierung und wir haben
in der debatte um die taxonomie gesehen
die die finanzmärkte haben richtig lust
auf die grüne transformation mit zu
ermöglichen
das ist tatsächlich so allianz munich re
ganz viele player haben sich auch dazu
positioniert dass sie gerne nicht die
taxonomie aufgeweicht haben wollten
sondern gerne nochmal klare regeln
hätten bessere rahmenbedingungen das was
auch gut funktioniert mit dem grünen
finanzmarkt und jetzt hier meine frage
zu unserem gemeinsamen projekt führender
sustainable finance standort zu werden
was ist ihre vision wie stellen sie sich
diesen pulsierenden um den standort
deutschland vor und was sind auf ihre
konkreten nächsten schritte die sie in
den nächsten monaten über auch die
etablierung nochmal des beirats
hinauszugehen gedenken vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin wir werden
eine sustainable finance strategie
entwickeln ihrem zentrum steht dass die
bundesregierung auch zukünftig wieder
gewinn bonds begeben wird ihr wirken mit
an der etablierung eines green bond
standards auf europäischer ebene
wir wollen auch die
finanzierungsinstrumente der
kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau in diese
richtung weiterentwickeln
dazu ist ja schon einiges an vorarbeit
geleistet worden und die bundesregierung
begrüßt dass die private seite also es
sind impulse aus unserer marktwirtschaft
nachhaltigkeitsaspekte unmittelbar auch
in der unternehmensberichterstattung
etablieren will insofern war die
bundesregierung mit ihrem
jahreswirtschaftsbericht so etwas auch
wie ein trendsetter weil auch im
privaten bereich inzwischen andere
indikatoren als nur finanzielle
kennzahlen ja bemüht und berichtet
werden
frau beck sie haben die möglichkeit zu
einer nachfrage
sehr gerne
super themen verfolgen wir und arbeiten
wir gerne zusammen weiter daran noch das
thema
mit dem präsidium ich hoffe das stimmt
der grüne balken es noch grün und wird
hoffentlich ganz groß die usa immer mehr
richtungen
also die oecd schätzt dass 35 prozent
der deutschen staatsausgaben in die
öffentliche auftragsvergabe gehen und
wie gedenken sie beim thema öffentliche
auftragsvergabe auch system
kriterien mehr zu integrieren das haben
sie davor
ich kann jetzt die zahl von 35 prozent
nicht im einzelnen bestätigen aber die
bundesregierung achtet auf
nachhaltigkeitskriterien bei der
öffentlichen auftragsvergabe
und wird das auch weiter tun ist ein
wichtiger aspekt auch der finanzierung
von vorhaben mit öffentlichen mitteln
gibt es eine nachfrage zu diesem thema
her kleinwächter aus der fdp fraktion
ja vielen deine frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister es geht
tatsächlich um den sustainable finance
beirat und dort natürlich die tatsache
dass der bundesrechnungshof festgestellt
hat dass dieser sustainable finance bei
war den sie beibehalten wollen der
bericht im endeffekt festgestellt hat
dass dieser beirat unwissenschaftlich
gearbeitet hat zb bei seinen
zwischenbericht
quellenangaben zur empirischen analysen
und umfragen gefehlt haben er macht
ihnen das keine sorgen wenn sie das
sozusagen als instrument weiterführen
wollen doch das ist anlass für eine
überarbeitung von zielsetzung mandat und
satzung des beirates
weitere nachfragen zu dem thema sehe ich
nicht dann gehen wir weiter und nächste
frage stellt für die fraktion die linke
victor perli
hin dass der minister in diesem jahr
will der mindestlohn auf 12 euro erhöht
werden das ist ein aus unserer sicht
längst überfälliger schritt in die
richtige richtung dafür haben lange
gekämpft ein problem ist allerdings dass
drauf wird selten hingewiesen dass
millionen beschäftigt in diesem land um
den mindestlohn betrogen werden der
deutsche gewerkschaftsbund hat eine
analyse gemacht auf basis von zahlen des
diw demnach bekommen 2,4 millionen
beschäftigt in diesem land den
mindestlohn nicht obwohl er ihnen
zusteht nun gibt es die besorgnis dass
bei einem steigenden mindestlohn dann
die
betrugsmanöver zu nehmen und in ihrem
arbeitsbereich ist ja auch die
finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit ganz toll
das heißt sie sind dafür zuständig
diesen mindestlohn auch durchzusetzen
betrug zu bekämpfen und ich frage sie
was tun sie dafür wenn in diesem jahr
ist wohnen so deutlich erhöht wird dass
der mindestlohn betrug endlich gestoppt
wird
sehr geehrter herr kollege zunächst
einmal geht die bundesregierung davon
aus dass das gros
und die absolute mehrzahl der
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber in
unserem land faire und auch rechtlich
sauber arbeiten
ich glaube das ist uns nicht gut tut so
eine allgemeine atmosphäre des
misstrauens zu schüren wir können froh
sein dass wir so viele arbeitgeberinnen
und arbeitgeber haben die gute
qualifizierte beschäftigung anbieten
zusammen mit dem bms wird mein haus da
wir über den zoll jahr zuständig sind
darauf achten dass es eine kontrolle
auch der arbeitszeiten und damit auch
der frage des mindestlohnes gibt die
möglichst bürokratie die arm erfolgt wir
sehen zwei große ziele zum einen
missbrauch und dumping zu verhindern zum
anderen aber auch eine belastung der
mittelständischen wirtschaft der
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber durch
überzogene bürokratie lasten zu
verhindern
herr berlin sie haben die möglichkeit zu
einer nachfrage
ja vielen dank dazu eine nachfrage also
natürlich die große mehrheit hält sich
einen gesetzlichen mindestlohn gar keine
frage aber durch meine anfrage ist
bekannt geworden dass sogar in der
fußball bundesliga
da wo die 1 millionen verdienen vier
vereine mindestlohn betrug begangen
haben und dort ermittelt werden musste
also jetzt sehen daran dass im bereich
wo viel geld verdient wird auch gegen
ministerin verstoßen wird sie haben zu
recht angesprochen dass natürlich die
große mehrheit sich daran hält aber es
ist für die die sich daran halten
natürlich ein problem dass es diejenigen
gibt die sich nicht daran halten weil
dort dann dumpinglöhne sozusagen
forciert werden und die konkrete frage
stellt sich natürlich schon wollen sie
denn auch einen deutlich steigenden
mindestlohn für mehr personal sorgen
damit mehr kontrolle möglich werden beim
teufel sie sich dort um hören bekommen
sie gesagt wir würden gern mehr
kontrollieren uns wie das personal wir
müssen hier quoten erfüllen das schaffen
es gar nicht deswegen brauchen wir von
der politik deutliche unterstützung also
mehr personal aufwuchs und ich habe weil
es nicht mal ein mail portal gibt bei
der bundesregierung wo man verstöße
melden kann selbst anmeldeportal ez
www.metrogroup.de da ging wöchentlich
sich fälle ein das zeigt so zu sagen es
gibt einen großen bedarf ich wollte
diese fälle an die behörden weiter damit
die behörden danken dem nachgekommen
sind wir nicht behinderter zuschauer
hier der bund auf gefolgt ist diese
ungerechtigkeit des menschen um ihren
lohn betrogen dann endlich ein ende zu
setzen ja sehr geehrter herr kollege
drastischer appell
wird von mir geteilt
es geht um fairness gegenüber den
beschäftigten übrigens geht es auch um
fairness gegenüber den ehrlichen
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgebern die ja
auch in eine wettbewerbssituation
geraten mit unehrlichen wettbewerbern
konkurrenten und deshalb werden wir das
uns mögliche tun um eine durchsetzung
des mindestlohns zu gewährleisten über
den zoll über die möglichkeiten der
dokumentation die wir auch hinsichtlich
digitaler möglichkeiten bürokratie
schonend weiterentwickeln wollen
vielen dank gibt es zu diesem thema
weitere nachfragen das sieht nicht so
aus dann hat jetzt das wort für die
fdp-fraktion der kollege markus herbrand
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister mit dem
vierten corona steuer hilfe gesetz
unterstützt die bundesregierung die
menschen und auch die unternehmen in der
aktuell ja noch immer sehr schwierigen
situation
die angedachten elf milliarden euro
entlastung werden gezielt eingesetzt und
helfen dort wo es wirklich am nötigsten
ist so stellt man sich
schnell ist und auch sehr umsichtiges
regierungshandeln vor gab es durch den
gerade erfolgten kabinettsbeschluss von
dem sie eben sprachen noch änderungen
gegenüber dem referentenentwurf
ja vielen dank herr kollege herr brand
auch für die sehr freundliche würdigung
des vierten corona steuer hilfe gesetzes
und seine makro ökonomische bedeutung
will das zum anlass nehmen auch zu
werben in diesem hause und auch
gegenüber dem bundesrat dieses vorhaben
zu unterstützen insbesondere mit blick
auf die degressive afa für bewegliche
wirtschaftsgüter
erhoffe ich mir in diesem haus und im
bundesrat unterstützen weil das ein
wichtiger baustein dazu ist das sehr gut
aus der krise kommen zu ihrer frage ja
es gab veränderungen gegenüber dem
referentenentwurf die zuschusszahlungen
des arbeitsgebers zum kurzarbeitergeld
getroffen haben die steuerfreiheit dort
und zum anderen das auch für empfänger
von grundsicherung für arbeitssuchende
die gewährten
sonderzahlungen nicht angerechnet werden
man hört dass im parlamentarischen raum
weitere veränderungen in vorbereitung
sind
sie haben die möglichkeit zu einer
nachfrage herbrand jobs wer gerne in
anspruch nehmen herzlichen dank vielen
dank herr minister wir haben ja immer
noch die situation dass die wirtschaft
in den vergangenen zwei jahren nicht so
hat investieren können wie es möglich
gewesen oder notwendig auch gewesen wäre
stichwort lieferketten wir brauchen aber
wachstum um aus den enormen schulden
auch herauszuwachsen die jetzt in den
vergangenen jahren aufgenommen wurden
plant die bundesregierung da weiteres ja
das tun wir ich habe es eben schon kurz
bei anderer gelegenheit angesprochen wir
bereiten ein instrument der sogenannten
super abschreibung im sinne einer
investitionszulage
prämie vor der bundeskanzler hat das in
seiner regierungserklärung angesprochen
es kann ein weiterer baustein ich sage
einmal hebel sein um private
investitionen anzuschieben insbesondere
in den transformativen bereichen von
klimaschutz und digitalisierung der
deutsche bundestag hat mit dem zweiten
nachtrag zum haushalt 2021 zudem ja auch
zusätzliche möglichkeiten
gesichert und auf dauer etatisiert mit
denen wir pandemie bedingt ausgebliebene
investitionen nachholen können das ist
makroökonomisch im internationalen
vergleich übrigens kein unübliches
instrument um aus der pandemie heraus
transformative aufgaben anzugehen und
die wirtschaftliche wettbewerbsfähigkeit
zu stärken
gibt es zu diesem themenkomplex noch
nachfrage herr gottschalk aus der fdp
fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister lindner sie
sprachen eben von super abschreibung und
damit eine stimulanz ein
wirtschaftswachstum zu erzeugen nun sind
wir uns alle einig wenn sich
investitionen aufstauen dann wird
sicherlich eine abschreibung keine
motivation bewegen und befördern sondern
eher dazu führen dass man mitnahme
effekt hat stimmen sie mir nicht
dahingehend zu und was wollen sie da tun
dass der wirtschaftsstandort die
langfristigkeit und die verlässlichkeit
einer investition ausmachen ob ich
investieren dazu gehören strompreise
fähre steuertarife dazu gehört ein
wirtschaftliches umfeld dazu gehören
befahrbare autobahn und natürlich auch
für die arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer
damit die überhaupt zur arbeit kommen
vernünftige und günstige bedingungen zur
arbeit zu kommen stichwort benzinpreise
das heißt ihre super abschreibung die
verpuffen doch und sie sind eigentlich
nur mitnahmeeffekt und für uns im
gegenteil nämlich zur verschuldung und
nicht zu einem konsolidierten haushalt
und einen vernünftigen
wirtschaftswachstum sehr geehrter herr
kollege bei ihrer aufzählung guter
standortbedingungen für unser land fehlt
vermutlich nicht zufällig die
qualifizierte einwanderung von
fachkräften
denn auch wie ist enorm wichtig das
wachstumspotenzial unseres landes zu
heben jedes verständige gespräch mit
mittelständlern und industrie würde
ihnen das zeigen in dem zusammenhang den
sie zu recht aufgemacht haben steuern
energiepreise infrastruktur
geschwindigkeit der öffentlichen
verwaltung
weltoffenes klima einer exportnation die
auf den weltmärkten erfolgreich sein
will und fachkräfte gewinnen will in
diese standortbedingungen passt aber die
idee einer sogenannten super
abschreibung im sinne einer
investitionszulage durchaus denn wir
wollen ja gerade die durch die pandemie
möglicherweise geschwächte
eigenkapitalbasis
des mittelstands stärken durch diese
abschreibung die liquidität sichert und
nicht beim fiskus einzieht
vielen dank ich habe eine weitere
nachfrage aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
herr minister das stichwort eigenkapital
starken führt bei mir dazu dass sie
soeben zu recht darauf hingewiesen haben
die fdp hatte keine 100% das bedaure ich
jetzt ein bisschen weniger als sie aber
eine gute eigenkapitalstärkung über ja
die thesaurierung begünstigung die haben
sie gemein mit den grünen und trotzdem
hat sie es nicht ins wahlprogramm
geschaffen können sie mir sagen wie ihre
ideen darf und das eigenkapital
innerhalb der unternehmen zu stärken
wenn sie die thesaurierung begünstigung
definitiv nicht auf den weg bringen
wollen
über diese fachliche frage können wir
gerne miteinander auch in den nächsten
jahren einen dialog führen das erste und
wichtigste was man tun kann um das
eigenkapital zu stärken ist es nicht zu
entziehen über eine höhere belastung der
wirtschaftssubjekte egal in welcher
rechtsform sie arbeiten deshalb ist aus
meiner sicht schon ein wichtiger beitrag
zur sicherung des standorts dass neben
dem bestehen auf der schuldenbremse eine
zweite leitplanke dieser regierung ist
dass es keine höhere steuerlast für
niemanden gibt und dass auch keine neuen
steuern eingeführt werden
[Applaus]
weitere fragen zu dem thema sehe ich
nicht dann ist der nächste frage stelle
aus der cdu csu fraktion fritz güntzler
sehr geehrter herr minister sie haben im
wahlkampf aber auch jetzt öffentlich
immer steuererhöhungen ausgeschlossen
der hoch geschätzte kollege christian
doerr den ich aus dem niedersächsischen
landtag kenne hat gesagt die kalte
progression ist eine heimliche und
politisch nicht legitimierte
steuererhöhung wenn sie jetzt im jahr
2022 nicht tätig werden um den tarif zu
ändern
sind sie doch faktisch für eine
steuererhöhung durch die hintertür wie
erklären sie uns das in eine
entscheidung über den steuertarif 2023
24 ist ja noch nicht getroffen sie
wissen der progression bericht wird im
herbst vorgestellt dann wird auch
entschieden über
steuerfreies existenzminimum
über den tarifverlauf im übrigen auch
über den regelsatz der grundsicherung
dann ist der richtige zeitpunkt der
steuertarif
2022 über den wurde entschieden mit dem
progression bericht
2020 den progress den tarifverlauf des
jahres 2022 hatte eine frühere
bundestagsmehrheit beschrieben
unterjährig den tarifverlauf von lohn-
und einkommenssteuer zu verändern ist
allerdings nicht empfehlenswert wegen
des enormen bürokratischen aufwands etwa
bei der lohnsteuer und in der
finanzverwaltung
vielen dank sie dürfen noch mal eine
nachfrage stellen wenn sie möchten ja
man möchte fast schon stellung zu nehmen
dass das eher eine schutzbehauptung ist
aber ich habe dann noch eine andere
frage herr minister wir haben die medien
auch entnehmen können dass sie für eine
anpassung der pendlerpauschale sind wenn
es dafür mehrheiten gibt meine frage
wäre kämpfen sie für diese mehrheiten
können wir damit rechnen dass aus ihrem
hause ein konkreter gesetzesentwurf
kommt ich habe es leider beim corona
steuer hilfe gesetz vier dass sie ja
mehrfach hier sehr gepriesen haben auch
der kollege herr brand sehr gepriesen
hat vermisst also es wäre doch eine gute
gelegenheit ist dort einzuspeisen der
bundesfinanzminister ist offen für eine
erhöhung der pendlerpauschale
es gibt ja im politischen raum eine
reihe von vorschlägen dazu ja
wahrgenommen dass etwa das land
niedersachsen eine solche initiative in
den bundesrat eingebracht hat auch
andere haben sich in dieser weise
geäußert
ich will schauen wie ist die
mehrheitsbildung dazu im deutschen
bundestag und und vielleicht darf ich
darauf ihre unterstützung bauen
natürlich ist der bundesfinanzminister
auch daran interessiert ob die
länderseite im falle einer erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale die entsprechenden
einnahmeausfälle auf der länderseite
übernehmen würden es handelt sich um
eine maßnahme je nach ausgestaltung die
zwischen 1,7 und 2,1 milliarden euro
gesamtstaatlich kostet und eine solche
maßnahme wäre nur bei einer mehrheit im
deutschen bundestag gemeinsam von bund
und ländern fiskalisch abzubilden ich
hoffe also sehr da sie aus niedersachsen
kommen dass sie bei herrn hilbers ein
gutes wort einlegen
ich freue mich
gibt es zu diesem thema weitere fragen
ja hier vorne aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
christian haase dankeschön frau
präsidentin der minister da muss ich
jetzt noch mal nachfragen das heißt sie
trauen sich nicht ihren eigenen
vorschlag in das gesetz rein zu
schreiben weil sie aufzuarbeiten auf den
ländern hoffen ich habe keinen
entsprechenden vorschlag gemacht wenn
sie meine entsprechenden äußerungen in
den medien verfolgen so habe ich gesagt
wenn es eine mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag also eine verständigung
insbesondere der koalitionsfraktionen
gibt und der bundesrat unterstützt dann
sei der finanzminister offen dafür und
genau das habe ich hier auch dargelegt
nachfrage geht nicht aber ich nehme
jetzt den herrn gottschalk dran und dann
dürfen sie gerne nochmal zu dem thema
ja vielen dank frau präsident nun kann
man ja progression entlastung über eine
rechts verschiebung her und leiten sie
können natürlich auch unseren tarif auf
rädern noch einmal da zustimmen aber sie
könnten natürlich auch ein versprechen
mit dem ich wir glaube ich eine mehrheit
im hause hätten realisieren indem sie
sagen sie schaffen den
solidaritätszuschlag
komplett ab denn er ist ja nach wie vor
gerade für den von ihm so präferierten
mittelstand und sie haben sich aber auch
als eine mittelstadt partei verstanden
von fundamentaler bedeutung weil er eben
in seiner progression ansetzt in einer
höhe ab etwa 70.000 brutto sie haben
auch vor der bundestagswahl auch hier im
plenum immer gesagt wir sind für eine
abschaffung die cdu hat sogar im
programm stehen hat sich sehr gerne mal
damit gewohnten wir haben ja nun ein
koalitionsvertrag gemacht da kann man
natürlich auch grundwerte der eigenen
programmatik gerne verbieten aber davor
da ist jedoch auch das wäre für viele
menschen und gerade für viele betriebe
in diesem spektrum eine wirkliche
erleichterung und würde tatsächlich von
kalter progression aber auch inflation
nachhaltig glaube ich für innovation
wachstum sorgen
der solidaritätszuschlag ist aus meiner
sicht
in ökonomischer hinsicht und auch
hinsichtlich der berechenbarkeit
politischer entscheidungen
entbehrlich er sollte entfallen aber ich
muss feststellen dass es hier in diesem
haus unter den demokratischen und
staatstragenden fraktionen keine
mehrheit gibt binder kummer gewohnt 2017
ist die vollständige abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags an der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion gescheitert jetzt
2021 gab es in der ampel konstellation
dafür keine mehrheit ich werde weiter
dafür werben dass es im demokratischen
zentrum dieses hauses dafür eine
mehrheit gibt gegenwärtig muss ich zur
kenntnis nehmen dass es eine solche
mehrheit nicht gibt
eine nächste nachfrage zu dem thema hat
der hase aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
danke schön dass ich noch mal nachfragen
darf herr minister ist es wäre es nicht
zeichen von handlungsfähigkeit wenn sie
ihre durchaus bestehende meinung zum
thema pendlerpauschale zumindestens dem
kabinett vorgelegt hätten das heißt wenn
sich da nicht durchgesetzt hätten hätten
wir schon mal gewusst für was sie
speziell stehen
für mich ist das mittel der wahl
inflationstendenzen in der breite der
bevölkerung zu beantworten der
steuertarif also der progression bericht
so ist er
2012 einmal auch mit stimmen der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
verankert worden und in dem zusammenhang
wird es einen umfassenden vorschlag
geben wenn im vorgriff darauf einzelne
maßnahmen von der koalition auf den weg
gebracht werden dann verschließe ich
mich dem nicht ich habe auch durchaus
vorstellungen die wir regierungsinternen
prüfen aber zunächst einmal gilt dass
das mittel der wahl um auf veränderungen
des preisniveaus zu reagieren die
regelmäßige anpassung von grund sage es
noch einmal grundsicherung steuerfreien
existenzminimum und tarifverlauf sind
weitere nachfragen zu dem thema sehe ich
jetzt nicht dann kommen wir zum nächsten
frage stelle aus der spd fraktion
johannes schraps
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr der
minister bevor das dem zeitlichen ablauf
der frage stellte der fragestunde zum
opfer fällt möchte ich gern noch mal auf
die europäischen reformvorhaben zu
sprechen kommen hat ihnen ihr vorgängern
gut bestelltes feld hinterlassen und
trotzdem stehen auch in der nächsten
zeit sehr viele wichtige wirtschafts und
finanzpolitische weichenstellungen auf
europäischer ebene bevor die stichworte
dazu sind sicherlich die debatte über
die weiterentwicklung des stabilitäts
und wachstumspakts aber auch die
umsetzung der globalen
mindestbesteuerung in europa die
vollendung der banken union oder eben
auch die debatte über neue eigenmittel
in der europäischen union sie haben
gerade die motivation der
bundesregierung ja schon mal
angesprochen trotzdem ist eine gewisse
prioritätensetzung sicherlich notwendig
und deshalb würde ich gerne noch mal
nachfragen welches aus ihrer sicht die
reformvorhaben sind die sie auf
europäischer ebene für vordringlich
lieber kollege shops es steht sogar noch
mehr an wir haben banken und
kapitalmarkt union stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt umsetzung des inklusiv
frameworks der oecd aber eben auch die
entscheidung über eigenmittel der
europäischen union das heißt es ist eine
sehr dichte agenda auf der europäischen
ebene
und es gibt ankündigungen seitens des
chefs der euro-gruppe der französischen
ratspräsidentschaft und der europäischen
kommission das in allen bereichen in
diesem jahr fortschritte erzielt werden
sollen dafür ist die bundesregierung
offen sie wird auch eigene vorschläge zu
gegebener zeit vorlegen wichtig ist für
uns erstens die finanzpolitische
eigenverantwortung der mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union wie der
europäischen wirtschafts und
währungsunion
zweitens die mobilisierung von privaten
und öffentlichen mitteln für die
transformativen vorhaben und drittens
wir wollen
sicherstellen dass wir einen
nachvollziehbaren verbindlichen
schuldenabbau fahrt in den nächsten
jahren erreichen und die
unterschiedlichen handlungsfelder die
sie genannt haben sind dort in
spezifischer weise verbunden
möchten sie noch eine nachfragen stellen
sehr gerne erstmal vielen dank für die
einordnung herr minister viele punkte
sind genannt worden die wir auch für
maßgeblich halten ich würd gern zur
banken union noch mal konkret nachfragen
da haben wir ja auch uns die vollendung
der banken union im koalitionsvertrag
auf die fahnen geschrieben ich würde
gern noch mal genau von ihnen wissen was
aus ihrer sicht jetzt die nächsten
konkreten schritte sind um im bereich
der vollendung der banken union voran zu
kommen wir haben ein gespräch
zwischen den finanzministerien und
finanzminister ich führe auch viele
bilaterale gespräch ich war gerade in
der frage kürzlich in rom sie wissen
dass zwischen deutschland und italien
einen gesprächspunkt die
berücksichtigung von staatsverschuldung
auf den bilanzen privater banken ist wir
wollen einen ganzheitlichen ansatz bei
der banken union das heißt wir wollen
sowohl die problematik
staatsverschuldung in banken
einlagesicherung
und
liquiditäts und kapitalflüsse zwischen
einzelnen mitgliedsstaaten der
europäischen union gemeinsam angehen
wichtig für deutschland ist eine starke
nationale komponente bei der
einlagensicherung muss erhalten bleiben
eine voll vergemeinschaftet
einlagensicherung ist nicht in unserem
interesse und die besondere situation
der institutssicherung unserer
sparkassen volksbanken und
genossenschaftsbanken muss
berücksichtigt werden die sind stark
beim regionalen angebot von
finanzdienstleistungen für die kundinnen
und kunden und die finanzierung des
mittelstands das darf nicht gefährdet
werden
dazu an der nachfrage von der kollegin
tillmann moment der kleine möchte
danke herr minister dass sie sich so
erfreulich für die institutssicherung
ausgesprochen haben aber ich wüsste
gerne noch mal konkret ihre meinung zur
vollendung der banken union können wir
uns darauf verlassen dass sie die
vergemeinschaftung der einlagensicherung
auch in form eines rückversicherungs
systems nur dann machen wenn die
verabredung zur risikoreduzierung in den
bankbilanzen tatsächlich eingehalten
wurden ich nenne beispielhafte risiko
untersetzung der staatsanleihen die non
performing loan reduzierungen die
insolvenzrechts harmonisierung europa
mir reicht ein jahr sie können sich
darauf verlassen dass ohne diese
maßnahmen mit mir eine banken union
nicht machbar also die insolvenzrechts
harmonisierung wird im zusammenhang mit
der kapitalmarkt union diskutiert aber
auch dort macht sich deutschland dafür
stark dass wir eine einheitliche
regelung insbesondere der
berücksichtigung der gläubiger situation
bei gegebenenfalls notwendigen
insolvenzverfahren erreichen können sie
haben jetzt die
rückversicherung im zusammenhang mit der
folge vergemeinschaftung der
einlagensicherung genannt das sind aber
eben
gegensätze das rückversicherungs modell
für dass sich deutschland einsetzt da
geht es ja gerade darum dass eine starke
nationale komponente erhalten bleibt und
deshalb eben keine voll
vergemeinschaftung der einlagensicherung
erfolgt in diesem sinne ist die antwort
auf ihre frage ja
vielen dank herr klein möchte sie haben
noch die gelinge zueinander frage
vielen dank herr präsident sie werter
herr minister ich frage tatsächlich zu
den deutsch-italienischen gesprächen die
sie angesprochen haben das ist ja durch
die presse gegangen dass es einen
deutsch italienischen aktionsplan geben
soll der vielleicht dann auch so was
ähnliches wird wieder vertrag von aachen
und meine frage bezieht sich genau auf
das was sie gerade ausgeführt haben wird
das was sie gerade ausgeführt haben teil
eines deutsch italienischen aktionsplans
seien vertraglich vereinbart werden wenn
ja was konkret wird er gerade besprochen
was konkret soll vereinbart werden von
dem was sie geschrieben haben das
bundesfinanzministerium strebt keine
bilaterale initiative an um vorschläge
für die banken union zu unterbreiten wir
haben einen multilateralen ansatz und
wir bevorzugen einen holistischen zugang
auf die banken union bei der die
unterschiedlichen aspekte frau kollegin
tillmann hat ja einige auch genannt
gemeinsam betrachtet werden also ein
einlage rückversicherungs system kann
nur eingeführt werden wenn es zugleich
fortschritte bei der überwindung des
servant bank nexus gibt also der frage
der staatsanleihen auf den bilanzen wenn
fragen der abwicklung von in schieflage
geratenen instituten geklärt sind und
sichergestellt ist dass es eine
beteiligung auch von eigentümern und
gläubigern gibt das heißt es braucht
einen holistischen ansatz die
bundesregierung strebt aber keine
bilaterale initiative mit irgendjemandem
an sondern wir bleiben multilateral und
für alle ansprechbar
vielen dank bevor ich zu einer weiteren
frage den kollegen mag das wort erteilt
frau von storch wenn ihre maske zu weit
ist weil sie mal runter rutscht sollten
sie vielleicht an dem bändchen bisschen
arbeiten als nächster fahrer ist der
kollege mario von der spd-fraktion frage
gestellt
präsident sehr geehrter herr
bundesminister der finanzen lindner
meine frage bezieht sich auf die
eingehende frage von herrn schraps
nochmal zu den europäischen
verhandlungen stichwort globale
mindestbesteuerung ist ja ein ganz
wesentlicher historischer meilenstein
auf dem weg zu einer neuen steuer
ordnung zur bekämpfung von unfairen
steuerwettbewerb ein projektes jahr von
ihrem amtsvorgänger olaf scholz von
ihnen jetzt gestützt wird und von
frankreich lange behelligt bearbeitet
wurde die französische
ratspräsidentschaft strebt jetzt eine
zügige umsetzung noch im ersten halbjahr
der richtlinie an und wir haben aber
signale vernommen beispielsweise von den
mitgliedsstaaten ungarn und polen dass
es eben so schnell geht das sicher etwas
auf der bremse sind wie bewertet die
bundesregierung das und was tun sie um
diese widerstände aufzuheben vielen dank
für die frage in der tat ich sehe auch
einen großen fortschritt in der
umsetzung des inklusiv framework der
oecd dem geht zehn jahre ein ganzes
jahrzehnt arbeit voraus über zehn jahre
wurde gearbeitet an der neuverteilung
der besteuerungs rechten und auf der
anderen seite der einführung einer
effektiven globalen mindestbesteuerung
zehn jahre arbeit dem zusammenhang ist
übrigens auch respekt zu zollen wolfgang
schäuble der das seinerzeit ja mit auf
den weg gebracht hat jetzt geht es an
die umsetzung dessen
es gibt innerhalb der europäischen union
die auffassung dass pilawa und peter
thul rechtlich zusammen betrachtet
werden sollen diese auffassung teilen
wer nicht ich habe auch im ecofin klar
gemacht für uns hat jetzt priorität die
umsetzung sollte zwei also effektive
mindestbesteuerung in der eu wir
unterstützen dort die französische
ratspräsidentschaft mag es einen
politischen zusammenhang geben mit
pillen so bestreiten wir das nicht
rechtlich ist der versuch beides zu
verbinden aber teil einer die la
torischen behandlung des inklusiv
framework und davon raten wir ab auch in
den bilateralen gesprächen die wir mit
noch skeptischen mitgliedsstaaten führen
so zu einer letzten frage im rahmen der
erfahrene bundesregierung rufe auf den
kollegen kai gottschall fdp fraktion
na gut ja sogar minister ich würde ihnen
einfach mal sechs zahlen nennen weil das
passt zu dem was sie gesagt haben 19 14
20 125 24 sich die leute zahlen sind die
höheren steuersätze in europa
ausgeglichenen ländern also nicht
irgendwelche exoten wie luxemburg oder
liechtenstein sollen umgang miteinander
italien
wir liegen mit 31 prozent da eigentlich
andere stützer und der
durchschnittssteuersatz liegt mit 20
prozent in europa und 23 prozent auch
deutlich unter dem satz
haben sie ja vorhin gesagt sie haben wir
keine nur prozent bekommen ob ich dem
aktiven 15 prozent die sie gewählt haben
haben insbesondere die hoffnungen damit
verbunden dass ich auf dem gebiet der
einkommensteuer auch auf die
unternehmenssteuerreform
herbeiführen die auf abzielt die
steuersätze auf deutsch unternehmen zu
senken was haben sie da geplant also die
der fdp zu gemessenen 15 prozent nämlich
einmal als kompliment
wir werden im bereich
steuerliche abschreibung skat bestände
ja in den nächsten jahren für die
deutsche wirtschaft insbesondere für den
mittelstand zu verbesserungen kommen
darüber hinaus halte ich in der tat es
für notwendig zu einer grundlegenden
reform von lhon einkommens und
körperschaftssteuer zu finden dazu hat
es in den vergangenen jahren und auch
jetzt im bundestag und bundesrat
allerdings keine mehrheit gegeben also
müssen wir uns auf das erreichbare
konzentrieren bei der frage der
energiekosten und bei anderen
standortbedingungen wenn sie steuersätze
in europa vergleichen dann bitte ich sie
auch zu berücksichtigen dass sich die
standortqualität und
wettbewerbsfähigkeit sich nicht nur am
steuersatz fest macht sondern auch an
dem was man dafür bekommt also
beispielsweise zustand der infrastruktur
versorgung und zugang zu fachkräften
marktposition weltweit rechtssicherheit
gute verwaltung
vielen dank eine weitere nachfrage
wir mit unserer gewerbesteuer in
deutschland vollkommen erste reihe von
das heißt kein anderes land zu holen
wir haben jetzt mit unserem programm die
gewerbesteuer abzuschaffen und dafür die
kommunen einen höheren anteil an der
einkommensteuer zu beteiligen das war
der organisation nehmen deutlich
entlasten aber auch im zeitplan bei der
kommunen wesentlich verbessern weil die
quantität steuer sehr
großen schwankungen unterliegt und
deswegen die planung und den kommunen
mit der gewerbesteuer sehr schwierig ist
dass man der einkommenssteuer wesentlich
einfacher wäre wäre das auch ein ansatz
für sie ihre regierung
sehr geehrter herr kollege
wenn sie die konjunktur realität der
gewerbesteuer überwinden wollen dann
rate ich davon ab ein steuer tausch mit
der einkommensteuer vorzusehen wenn sie
die konjunktur reagiert reduzieren
wollen dann empfiehlt sich
einen stärkeren umsatzsteueranteil
vorzusehen da die verbrauchssteuern
stetiger in ihrem aufkommen sind aber
das sage ich nur als fachliche
entgegnung weil sie ein modell
angedeutet haben politisch
nehme ich zur kenntnis dass die
kommunalen spitzenverbände
unisono an der gewerbesteuer festhalten
wollen und ich glaube es ist ganz gut
wenn wir im deutschen bundestag nicht
über die köpfe unserer
kommunalpolitikerinnen und
kommunalpolitiker
hinweg entscheiden sondern deren
befindlichkeiten wünsche und interessen
sehr genau wahrnehmen
vielen dank dass sie keine weiteren
fragen zu dem rund und eine letzte und
dann ist schluss
minister sie haben die notwendigkeit
benannt der modernisierung des deutschen
unternehmens steuerrechts haben aber
auch von abschreibungen gesprochen ich
nehme an dass diese modernisierung wird
sich nicht nur auf die abtreibungsfrage
begrenzen können wir damit rechnen dass
aus ihrem hause von ihnen persönlich ein
konkreter vorschlag ein umfassender
vorschlag zur modernisierung des
deutschen unternehmenssteuer kommt
wir werden bei einem
unternehmenssteuerrecht und im
steuerrecht insgesamt ihnen als
gesetzgeber vorschläge unterbreiten aber
noch einmal sagen dass
es
festlegungen der
koalitionsparteien gibt so etwas ist der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion aus der
vergangenheit ja wohl bekannt die
breitflächige entlastungen etwa bei der
körperschaftsteuer nicht zulassen das
sind politische realitäten und ich sag
mal so die nächsten wahlkämpfe der
parteien sollen ja auch spannend bleiben
also darf man nicht jetzt schon jedes
problem lösen
herzlichen dank damit beende ich die
befragung bedanke mich herr minister
lindner für ihre
standfestigkeit über eine stunde hinweg
eine gute stunde hat der
bundesfinanzminister in relativ fragen
der abgeordneten beantwortet zum auftakt
dieser sitzungswoche ein breites
themenfeld über steigende energiepreise
mindestlohn verstöße
eigenkapitalstärkung bei unternehmen
aber auch über das corona steuerhilfen
gesetzt was das kabinett heute auf den
weg gebracht hat der erste sitzungstag
in dieser plenarwoche und wir melden uns
wieder live ungefähr 15 15 da gibt es
nämlich eine aktuelle stunde kurz vor
dem zweiten jahrestag des rassistisch
motivierten anschlags in hanau befasst
sich der bundestag nämlich mit dem kampf
gegen
rechtsextremismus jetzt gebe ich aber
erstmal zurück ins bonner studio zu
meiner kollegin claudia d
ja viele nehmen dank david clark nach
berlin wir freuen uns dann später wieder
in den bundestag zurück zu kehren es
gibt uns aber jetzt erst mal gelegenheit
uns mit dem thema des tages zu befassen
die korona regeln was beschließen
kanzler scholz um die
ministerpräsidentinnen heute im vorfeld
zum treffen verzeichnet die whu weltweit
weiter sinkende corinna neuinfektionen
ein trend der sich auch hierzulande
fortsetzt den 4